if some of you spent as much time and
energy focusing on your own success
focusing on the success of your family
focusing on the success of your career
as you focus on your sports team and on
politics
you'd be wildly successful CS Lewis said
you can't go back and change the
beginning but you can start where you
are and change the ending you get to
decide you are not a victim you are not
a victim you may have been a victim of
something but sitting here today looking
forward you get to decide what you will
tolerate in your life you control the
controllables a victim of circumstances
is someone who decides to sit down and
stay in the circumstances all of us have
had bad things said about us done to us
happen to us and at that moment we were
a victim but if you remain in a victim
status you will not progress and become
successful in any area of your life your
parenting your marriage your career your
spiritual walk your physical condition
or your wealth building your career any
of it anything you do you you have to
decide I am NOT a victim of what
happened I love the CS Lewis quote it's
great you cannot go back and change the
beginning but you can start where you
are and change the ending we see people
and admire people our whole lives that
have overcome something the overcomers
are always the
heroes in the story aren't they and in
real life we just look at them and say
wow you're impressive look at where you
started
and what you have overcome look at what
you were a victim of but didn't remain a
victim the victim mentality gives you an
excuse to not win you don't understand I
dot dot dot you've never been like me
and only lived on dot dot dot now maybe
maybe not
I've lived on nothing worst year my life
I made six thousand dollars one year boy
that sucked
I was a victim of the tax law change
under the Reagan administration so did
Ronald Reagan ruined my life nope the
congressman my life did the IRS run my
life did banks were in my life I went
bankrupt because of all of them and
moves that they made and moves that I
made that put me in the firing line so
when those idiots all pulled the trigger
I got shot but I stepping in front of
bullets so I was asking for it I didn't
know any better I was dumb ignorant
that's 30 years ago so my victim or not
my Todd says
I've never been poor have only been
broke poor is a state of mind sometimes
the biggest obstacle those of us who
started with nothing have is between our
ears that we believed as Henry Ford used
to say if you think you can or you think
you can't you're right I heard my whole
life growing up well the little man just
can't get ahead
you don't understand Dave the little man
the game is rigged you have to have
somebody to do it for you because you
don't have a chance of doing it yourself
I didn't hear that in my family but I
heard it with people on you my family
always told us we could do anything as
if we had some kind of super power and
turns out the superpower is belief
believing that you can well nobody my
family ever went to college so go to
college nobody my family is ever a
millionaire so go be a millionaire
nobody my family dot dot dot so what go
be the first one might be time to change
your bunch your bunch might need
changing they may be saying about about
this old man's bunch someday but we
changed we decided we're not borrowing
money anymore we made the decision we're
not living like this anymore we made the
decision that that's not how things work
so you control the controllables you
can't control what other people say you
can't control what other people do you
can only control what you do but the
interesting thing is what you do has
more to do with your winning or losing
than what everybody else put together
does what happens in your house is a
whole lot more important than the White
House it's amazing to me just watching
social media some of you people just
lost your minds out there we were
laughing today that in the [ __ ] you know
you posted
or you post something Instagram
somewhere around the fifth or sixth
comments someone says yeah but Trump it
like yeah but Trump and then gave me to
do with Trump
it's just they want to start an argument
everybody wants to fight and if you just
say yeah but Trump you can start an
argument
pro Trump versus anti Trump or whatever
and I Got News for you he has not sent
me any money nor am i sitting up nights
waiting for him to send me any money
Barack Obama didn't send me any money
George W didn't send me any money and
I'll go on down the list the Clinton
certainly didn't send me any money
they didn't the best possible thing they
could have done and some of them did it
and some of them didn't was allowing me
to keep some of my money that by the way
was my money it wasn't yours by changing
the tax law and allowing me to keep
something I earned rather than taking it
from me against my will
that's the most a political candidate
can ever offer because they're not
sending you any money they're not
sending you any money what happens in
their house isn't not that important if
some of you spent as much time and
energy focusing on your own success
focusing on the success of your family
focusing on the success of your career
as you focus on your sports team and on
politics
you'd be wildly successful the amount of
brainpower knowledge passion and energy
that some of you spend on your sports
teams and on politics arguing about
Trump one way or the other arguing about
these crazy conch butt congressman's
that are socialist and all this stuff
arguing about all this stuff one way or
the other if you spent all that time and
energy on you and your success your
family success
you'd be wildly successful I'm not
amazing I meet people who have more
sports trivia stored in their brain it's
so impressive how much brain power they
have but they cannot tell you the
balancing their 401k they can't even
spell 401k they don't have their term
life insurance in place they don't have
their wills done they haven't been on a
budget they're deeply in debt but they
can tell you every stinkin thing about a
sports team C and I'm not against sports
and if you're a sports trivia person
that's just fine but make sure you're
successful before you spend all your
time admiring other people's success
make sure that your career make sure
you're reading a book that causes you to
win that causes you to be a better dad
that causes you to be a better husband
that causes you to be better at your
work make sure you're doing that stuff
before you worship other people's
success spend your energy and your time
on that you can't go back and change the
beginning but you can start where you
are and change the ending I love that